[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Sam's in
Austin Texas Hi Sam how are you I'm
doing pretty good how youall doing
better than I deserve how can we
help well um you know I'm calling
because you know I've uh over the years
we or last couple years we bought a
house things seem to be going okay and
then we ended up getting kind of taxed
on the actual build of the house and
that just kind of started a slippery
slope where we started having to pay
more than what our mortgage originally
was and we ended up relying on a lot of
credit cards and it got really bad and
right now we're in I'm I'm especially in
collections for our of cards and my wife
has a few she was sued I got a case
coming as well and I I just don't really
know where to turn or how to turn this
around it almost seems kind of
hopeless sorry Sam
how much credit card debt do is is their
total uh probably
around probably 15 to 16,000 and how
much income do you guys bring in every
month uh every month um about
6,000 how much is your house payment
2,100 okay how much are your car
payments we only have one car payment
and it's 250 and as far as like the the
the mortgage it's uh when we were being
taxed on the Improvement after about a
year of having a lower payment it was
about
2700 and now we're down to I finally
paid off the um the uh overage on the
escrow and um now you know the 2100 is
about normal okay all right and what do
you guys do for a
living uh I'm in technical support and
she works uh in a dental office okay
your mortgage is high your car payment
is all car payments are bad this one's
not super bad um the credit cards are uh
the way you were talking I thought you
were going to tell me you had 100,000 in
credit card debt um the weight the
weight that you're emotionally carrying
listening to your voice um I'm
pleasantly surprised it's only 15 me too
yeah I think the mortgage being a third
of your take-home is really what's and
it was higher than that for a while but
even that where where else do are you
guys just disorganized and you were
living in panic and money's just flying
out of there and you had no idea where
it was
going that's that's a pretty good way to
put it yeah yeah okay cuz I mean your
numbers aren't as as bad as the they
don't indicate you should even be behind
yeah and and and I agree with you there
because when I you know when I sit there
and kind of add up numbers and you know
look at it that way I I look at it I'm
like okay this is how many kids have you
got we have five total oh they and how
old are they uh they range from
teenagers down to seven
okay how many are in
daycare none they're all in school okay
okay well you and well our old as she
works and um but you know she she just
graduated high school yeah but um and
and the main thing is is that you know I
think what okay H how many credit cards
are you behind
on uh probably I would say it's pretty
good number probably about 8 to 10 so
there's a whole bunch of little ones
yeah yeah and you're behind on almost
all of them uh I've got four myself that
I you said two have gone two have gone
to
collections no they're pretty much all
in collections but I have four that I've
made payment arranges with but two of
them um have B lawsuits yeah you said
your wife got sued on one of them right
filed
lawsuits yeah oh that's cute on how
much uh hers is a little bit over 3,000
and the same for mine oh man okay
let me just tell you you live in Texas
am I got that right is that the truth
that's correct
okay well their lawsuits useless they
can't garnish she wages or take a lean
on a house in Texas right so it's just
hanging their lawsuits hanging out there
in The Ether it's just dangling out
there in the nothingness it has there's
nothing they can do about it CU with
hers we hired a lawyer and they working
on the
case was the fear thing at the time know
that's the thing Sam what you like
looking at the numbers that you've given
us maybe there's more debt out there
that you haven't mentioned but I think
that you're way more what you're feeling
is way more emotional than it is
financial it's like oh my gosh I've got
12 credit cards they're suing us you
know the kids are it's like all these
things going on and if you just stop for
a moment if we really look at the
numbers and look at the math there's no
reason that we can't list these from
smallest to largest CU like Dave said
most of them are probably lower balances
cuz there's tons of them and they're
only equaling up to 15 to 16,000 so my
guess is that if you can just kind of
pull all of this out of space get it
down on paper like I said list them
smallest to largest figure out what it
looks like for you guys to get an extra
one to $2,000 in every month and you're
knocking them out like dominoes you're
going to feel so much better how many
cars do you
own um we we have two that we use for
getting the kids around um our oldest
son has his own that he uses for school
and and and you bought it for
him uh it was he's a stepson and his dad
gave it to him as a okay all right yeah
it's just a l truck okay I'm just trying
to find out what's going on here all
right so what did this lawyer tell you
he could do that the law has done for
you in Texas they basically said that no
no they just basically said that they
could either get the case dismissed or
work out some type of lower settlement
essentially that's all they offered okay
well the case is not going to get
dismissed you you owe the money you lost
right you owe the money you didn't pay
it you lose ding okay now then can we
settle it for Less well sure it's 3,000
bucks they can't collect it in Texas so
of course you can settle it for Less um
and you can do that with all you can do
that with all of these by the way and
next time don't use a lawyer what did
you pay the lawyer a 750 okay I sure
hope he get 750 off the balance at least
earns his keep I I don't know how you
took your money in good conscience but
um uh all right now the the main thing I
I worry about is like uh because I've
heard that you know I understand they
can't bur my wages but they could like
take it from my bank account not unless
you give them the not unless you give
them access to your bank account well
they lean you can take a lean on it in
Texas that's true well don't keep if you
got a bunch of money in your bank
account I guess we'd pay the bills
huh yeah I mean I really don't at the
time but at you know at the current
moment but you know working on this here
and building up you
no I'm just saying I'm just saying the
if if there was $10,000 in your bank
account you wouldn't have called me yeah
so you don't have any money in your bank
account so it's not a big fear yeah okay
okay so anyway what we've got to do is a
get organized and get a very detailed
plan and B let's prioritize first thing
is hous is paid food then house then
lights and water then car are you behind
on the car no no no okay good stay
current on the car go to work and we're
going to get you on an every dollar
budget with Jade and put you in one of
her webinars when's your next webinar oh
gosh it's not till November I don't know
that we have we'll get you we'll get you
plugged into an every dollar webinar so
you can learn how to do a budget with
your wife and uh we'll put you into
financial piece university because
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to take care of food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
first you've got the money to do that
and then we're going to force rank these
things and work them through and lump
some settlement all of them each
smallest largest I'm not paying payments
on them anymore I'm going to lump some
settlement you're behind uh the lawsuit
is got no teeth where you
live okay okay so just argue with them
and say I'm broke I owe you
$3,000 uh you say it's 5,000 after you
added a bunch of fees um I have 2,000 if
you'll take that and give me that in
writing that that's a settlement in full
remember that phrase and no electronic
access to your checking account as Jade
said they will never know where your
checking account is but um settlement in
full in writing and then I'll send you
$2,000 oh you won't do that did you know
there's nine other credit cards that
will one of them's going to take the
money I got you on the phone last chance
going once going twice I'm going to the
next card okay second card here's what
we're going to do I just Tong up on the
other guy cuz he's an idiot let's see if
you are all right and we're going to
settle this going once and going twice
and you're going to work your way
through this and then you cycle back
through after you find they get one to
take the money then you pile up a little
more money and you start the whole
process again remember last time I
called you when you didn't take the deal
you sure you don't want to take it cuz
I'm here with another deal and I'm
getting ready to go on to the second one
going once going twice and this is how
you deal with these people cuz credit
card collectors are scum you can tell
they're lying if their mouth is moving
so beat the snot out of them and get
this cleaned up that's what you do this
is the Ramsey Show